good afternoon my name is Guy Kawasaki
and I am a resident of Silicon Valley I
have a sort of long history I'm pretty
old many of you may know of me from this
context so I was Apple's second software
evangelist so I am here today to talk to
you about the art of evangelism it's
something that I learned in Macintosh in
the Macintosh division as well as an
entrepreneur and as a chief evangelist
of canva so these are the skills that I
would like to pass on to you so that you
can in the words of Steve Jobs dent the
universe make the world a better place
for those of you who have seen a lot of
hi-tech speakers I think you'll relate
to this there are two fundamental
qualities of most hi-tech speakers first
almost all of them suck and second
almost all of them go long and that is a
deadly combination you know if you suck
and you go long Wow if you suck in your
short okay if you're great and you're
long okay but sucking and going long bad
combination
double whammy and so what I do is I use
the top 10 format for my speeches so I
have 10 key points for you so in case
you think I suck you know approximately
how much longer I'll suck because I'm
exactly ten points for you okay so point
number one and I think this is the key
to marketing and engineering and
therefore evangelism
by the way evangelism comes from Greek
terminology or Greek words meaning
bringing the good news so as a Macintosh
evangelist is the canva evangelist I was
bringing the good news of Macintosh or
Macintosh would make people more
creative and productive canva enables
you to create great graphics and so by
bringing the good news I learned that
this is the most important concept in
marketing if you can get this concept
game over it's all you need so it is the
2x2 matrix the horizontal axis is the
value of your product the vertical axis
is the uniqueness or degree of
differentiation of your product so we'll
go through all four corners on the
bottom right hand corner that's where
you have something
it's valuable but it is not unique so
it's useful it's just not unique it is
Michael Dell slapping the same version
of Windows on the same hardware you can
make a lot of money there but it's
always about price in the opposite
corner you have something that's truly
unique but it is not variable it is
useless in that corner you are just
plain stupid
in the bottom left front corner you are
stupid and it's crowded with other
stupid people that bottom left corner I
like to cite the dot-com days in
particular pets calm so pets calm let's
reminisce about pets calm in pets calm
you would buy dog food online and the
sort of proposition of pets calm was
that now we can sell you direct we can
eliminate the retail distribution
channel discount dog food
so yes you discount dog food but then
you have to add back shipping and
handling so the reason why pets.com
wasn't that valuable is because yes you
discounted at the top line but then you
had to add back shipping and handling
because you had to get the dead cow in
the can to the dog food to the dog owner
and also somebody had to be at home when
UPS dropped off the dead cow in the can
if you weren't there it left your little
tag that said we attempted to drop off
the dead cow in the can no one was home
we're gonna attempt to drop off the dead
cow in the can tomorrow if no one's home
again we're gonna send the dead cow in
the can back to the factory so it was
inconvenient and just as expensive why
was pets calm in such a crowded market
it's because people in Silicon Valley
like me fell for this pitch never use a
pitch along these lines okay there's 300
million Americans one in four owns a dog
75 million dogs each dog eats two cans
of dog food per day total addressable
market of a hundred and fifty million
cans of dog food per day and dog food is
not a b2b business it's not a five day a
week business Monday through Friday
dogs eat every day we're talking b2c or
more accurately b2d dogs eat every day
so you take 150 million cans of dog food
per day how hard could it be to get 1%
of that with my
Rockstar programmer co-founder 1% of 115
million cans of dog food per day is one
and a half million cans of dog food per
day times 365 we're talking 5 or 600
million cans of dog food a year that's
why there was pets calm my pets calm a
pest calm Peapod pets calm web and pets
calm there are 16 ways to buy dog food
online but the corner you truly want to
be in is in the upper right hand corner
so whether you wear an engineering hat
or marketing hat that's where the action
is with canva we're trying to create
something that's powerful easy to use
and cheap the holy grail of creating
graphics you know Macintosh was in that
upper right hand corner it was the first
computer that mere mortals could use
when iPod first came out it was the only
way you could get a lot of music legally
and inexpensively Breitling makes a
watch called a Breitling emergency and
if you unscrew the big knob at the five
o'clock position it starts broadcasting
an emergency signal that emergency
signal is caught by planes if you pull
that thing out and you you set this
alarm off next thing you know kevin
costner is in the Coast Guard helicopter
in the basket coming to rescue you
that's a watch that can save your life
there are not many watches that can save
your life
Mercedes makes a smart car you know all
of us have cars that can park parallel
to the curb how many of us have cars
that can park perpendicular to the curb
so I think this explains most of
evangelism and marketing which is make a
product that is unique and valuable if
its unique but not valuable
you always always be stupid if you are
valuable but in a unique you always have
to compete on price if you're not unique
and not valuable you're just pathetic
don't even you know you don't even
register on the radar this is the holy
grail of evangelism getting in the upper
right-hand corner of this graph number
two number two is my insight and it took
me a long time to figure this out you
have to remove all the speed bumps I
think that one of the things that gets
in the way of new product of the option
is that
you get too close to the product and you
think Oh people won't mind doing this
kind of thing they won't mind giving you
their credit card even though you're
giving them a free account they won't
mind having to do all kinds of rekeying
of data because our database is so great
and these kinds of speed bumps count
there are a terrible friction upon new
product adoption and evangelism a very
good test for this by the way is not
that you are willing to go through with
this it's to give it to your spouse or
your parents and say sign up for our
service see if you can do it
remove the speed bumps number three
number three is my observation that if
you want to create a great company today
you have to attack the incumbents from
below for example with canva you know
fundamentally we're competing with Adobe
right so adobe has photoshop and
illustrator and so there are two
strategies one strategy would be well
you could make something that's more
powerful than photoshop more powerful
than illustrator that would be the go
above them I think the way to attack an
incumbent is always to go from beneath
them so less powerful simpler cheaper
easier to use if you attack from below
you can always move up but if you attack
from above you cannot move down with
Macintosh you know we try to attack the
IBM PC from below we weren't trying to
make a computer more powerful than the
IBM PC we're trying to make a computer
more easy more inexpensive more fun to
use so my advice as you try to attack
the incumbents is attack from below not
from above number four number four is
that my observation in evangelism is
that you have to learn to ignore
people's titles and pedigrees that just
because they're the CIO CMO CTL CX o
just because they went to well Yale in
particular right now it doesn't mean
that they're competent or smart and Maya
variation is that the higher you go in
most organizations the thinner the air
and the thinner the air the more
difficult it is to support intelligent
life and so if you try to enter an
organization from the top inevitably you
will be dealing with the dumbest people
in the organization ignore people's
titles and pedigrees when you are trying
to evangelize something you don't care
about their titles and pedigrees all you
care about is that they get it there was
no CIO or CTO in a fortune 500 company
that grok Macintosh it was always the
graphic designer the artist the
photographer the slide maker the
presentation the newsletter maker was
all the people at the Middle's and the
bottoms get in through the bottom get in
through the middle ignore people's
titles and pedigrees number five number
five is you have to learn to suck up it
is a fact of life that you have to suck
up just deal with that don't be proud
you have to suck up to be in the feature
that the you know the Play Store you
have to be you have to suck up to be
featured at the Apple Store you have to
be sucking up to you know getting the
start on Android program it's a cost of
doing business get over it it's worth it
at one point I was running the Apple
developer Channel so I was on the
opposite side of this discussion and we
would run Co marketing with developers
and you know what we worked with the
people that we liked you have to have
good products don't get me wrong but it
was people who you know wanted our help
who were nice to us it wasn't just
because they had a great product and I
learned a very humbling and important
lesson that sometimes in life you just
have to suck up because man being on the
front page of a App Store can make your
product succeed so get over it
learn to suck up number six number six
is to learn to niche yourself you know I
think many people when they look at a
company
a successful company they sort of forget
the first 20 years of the company so you
look at something like Microsoft or
Apple and you say wow look at look at
Apple they have Hardware they have
software they have applications they
have content look at Microsoft if
hardware/software gaming they have cloud
they have everything and so we need a
grand plan look at Google they have
search they have analytics they have
cars they have you know blocks of salt
that's gonna store energy they have ways
to count fish in fish farms they have
everything so there's this grand scheme
so your two guys in the garage two gals
in a garage a guy and a gal in the
garage and you think we're gonna be like
Google and Microsoft and Apple so
someday we need an operating system we
need an app we need hardware we need
software we need cloud we need ecommerce
we need the whole thing that's not how
it works I think the way it works is you
own one niche at a time you get one
niche and then you get another niche and
then you get another niche and one day
you wake up and my god you have achieved
worldwide domination it is not because
you planned for worldwide domination it
is because to use a bowling pin analogy
you knocked over one pin and then
another pin and then another pin and
then you turned around and one day you
had a strike but it wasn't because you
had all those pins knocked down on one
ball you took them down one at a time a
very good academic orientation for this
or explanation of this is crossing the
chasm by Geoffrey Moore I highly
recommend that book crossing the chasm
by Geoffrey Moore the point here is
niche thyself go after one niche then
another and another and another and wake
up and declare victory with worldwide
domination number seven number seven is
stolen from Chairman Mao though I fail
to see how he ever implemented this
which is 100 flowers blossom and by this
I mean when you have innovated when you
have shipped your product you know you
take your best shot at positioning and
branding with Macintosh we thought we
had a spreadsheet
database and word processing machine
basically we were 0 for 3 in the mid-80s
people weren't embracing McIntosh for
spreadsheet database the word processing
they embraced Macintosh for desktop
publishing desktop publishing was a gift
from God to Apple it saved Apple without
desktop publishing there would be no
Apple today I believe in God and one of
the reasons why I believe in God is
there is no other explanation for
Apple's continued survival than a
benevolent God so God gave Apple
PageMaker and PageMaker created a field
of flowers called desktop publishing but
you know what we were focusing on
spreadsheet database and word processor
not desktop publishing a more analog
example suppose you work for Avon CMO of
Avon and you have this product it's
called Skin So Soft what's the purpose
of Skin So Soft you don't need a PhD to
figure this out
Skin So Soft is about beauty and hope
and lusciousness and all that good
aesthetic stuff and then you find out
that moms are buying skin so soft as an
insect repellent OMG this was not your
intent your positioning was not better
for your children than DDT that was not
the plan but I tell you something you
know what if moms want to buy Skin So
Soft for their children's insect
repellent hallelujah declare victory you
know if people want to use canvas for
things that we never intended hallelujah
declare victory for those of you not
from Silicon Valley let me explain
something to you the way it works in
Silicon Valley is we throw a lot of
things against the wall a very few
number stick then we go up to the wall
and we paint the bullseye around it and
we declare victory we hit the bull's eye
you can always hit the bull's eye if you
paint the bullseye after you see what
sticks ok let a hundred flowers blossom
don't be proud you think you have a
spreadsheet database at a word
processing machine
come to find your health do you have a
desktop publishing oisin hallelujah
declare victory we intended Macintosh to
be a desktop publishing machine let a
hundred flowers blossom number eight
number eight is the hardest lesson to
learn for any Evangelist which is
churned baby churn it means that you
take version 1 of your product and make
it 1 1 1 2 1 3 1 4 1 5 2.0 oh my god you
know I used to think that a revolution
and innovation was an event it's not an
event it is a process it's one of the
hardest things to learn because you
think you ship and then your biggest
problem will be can you scale fast
enough a few times in my career I would
like to have that as my problem you know
can we scale fast enough scaling fast
enough is not usually the problem the
problem is usually can we get the dogs
to eat the food at all turn baby turn
it's great discipline number nine number
nine is that it is very important to
build an ecosystem if you truly want to
achieve success because an ecosystem
will do things that you don't want to do
you cannot do maybe you shouldn't even
do I mean imagine Android without you
imagine iOS without the iOS developers
imagine all the software companies
without their dealers and their VARs and
their consultants and all that kind of
stuff I mean if you're a restaurant is
it just the food or is it also the
relationship with the waiters and the
waitresses with the valet company with
the organic farms with the totality of
the community build an ecosystem an
ecosystem will rescue you an ecosystem
will do things that you cannot do you
should not do you don't want to do part
of the technical ramifications of
building an ecosystem is you always have
api's and you have documentation
you know when Apple announced the iPhone
in 2007 the first version of the iPhone
was a closed architecture
you could only add functionality to the
iPhone by used by creating Safari
plugins a year later Apple completely
reversed itself and made it possible to
make native apps and the rest is history
if we had stuck with a closed system and
not had a iOS ecosystem
I think iPhone would have failed the key
is to build an ecosystem you are part of
the Android ecosystem also build an
ecosystem for your product number 10
number 10 is you have to learn to ignore
naysayers evangelists selling dreams are
always going to encounter naysayers
there are two kinds of naysayers in the
world
I call them bozos okay there are two
kinds of bozos in the world one kind of
bozo is sloughing Lee disgusting pocket
protector Japanese watch rusty car a
loser you look at that person you say
you are a loser that bozo is not
dangerous because only losers listen to
losers the dangerous bozo is the winner
bozo the winner bozo dresses in all
black which is afraid to say that today
but the winner bozo is rich and famous
the winner bozo is well known and many
people think that rich and famous equals
smart rich and famous 50% of the time
equals lucky not smart you know
if rich and famous always parse to smart
you know arguably we would listen to
Kanye West about constitutional law Tom
Cruise about spirituality kim kardashian
about how to travel in france safely i
mean you you cannot make this assumption
that rich and famous equals smart so I
need to inoculate you because I think
that Bo's asset is just like the flu how
do you fight both ah city and naysaying
you get a little bit of it in your life
so when you encounter it in your career
as an entrepreneur as an employee when
you encounter big flu big balls ah s'ti
big saying big negativity big stupidity
you've built up the resist
so I have one example here for you there
is no reason why anyone would want a
computer in their home Ken Olsen founder
of deck mean of you are too young to
know but deck was an extremely
successful mini computer company and so
Ken Olson was an extremely successful
innovator revolutionary he changed the
face of computing we went from mainframe
to mini because of Ken Olson and Dec so
imagine you're Steve and woz Larry and
Sergey and someone says to you you know
you need some adult supervision you need
someone who's been there and done that
someone who's built the hardware company
at the scale had to you know encounter
all these challenges someone like Ken
Olson Steve and woz go talk to Ken Olson
get him to invest get him to be a
director get in to be an advisor so
let's just say you get in a elevator one
day and there he is Ken freaking Olson
and you say to mr. Olson you know mr.
Olson we have a different vision for
computing we think that computer should
be small and cheap and easy to use small
and cheap and he's so small so cheap so
easy to use mr. Olson that you could
have a computer in your house mr. Olson
and mr. Olson says son let me tell you
something there is no reason why anyone
would want a computer in their house
let's say they wanted to balance their
checkbook they will get in their car
drive back to the office and use quicken
running on a deck mini computer what's
the problem so before you ruin your life
learn COBOL or Fortran and come work for
deck and there would be no Apple today
so I'm trying to tell you that you know
overcoming bilasa T overcoming
negativity is a big challenge because it
often comes from people that you think
you should respect and they know what
they're doing I'm not saying that
everybody who tells you you'll fail
is wrong frankly most of the time
they'll be right but if you always
listen to those people and never try you
will never know and that is the worst
outcome of all there's no reason why
anyone would want a computer in their
home and this is my last slide this is
my last slide because I think that this
should be your mantra this is how you
should approach your life if you're a
entrepreneur an innovator in the tech
business most of the time when you see
this it's the opposite way some things
need to be seen to be believed
if you show me a Macintosh if you show
me an Android if you show me iOS if you
show me canva if you show me privee when
you have millions of users of all these
products that's when I'll believe it
that's not how the world works in
innovation the world works like this if
you believe in Macintosh if you will
create products for Macintosh if you
believe in Android and you'll create
products for Android if you believe in
canva and start creating graphics if you
believe in privy and start creating a
social network because of the ecosystem
because of the installed base because of
the use of it then it'll become true and
you will truly truly see it some things
need to be believed to be seen so the
art of evangelism is all about getting
into that upper right-hand corner right
you want something unique and valuable
you're gonna need to suck up come to
grips with that you're gonna need to
reduce all the friction make it so easy
to sign up you know imagine if you're an
evangelist for the environment you have
the Sierra Club you're in charge of
Sierra Club man membership and you said
to people well if you want to be an
evangelist for the column for the
environment
you have to donate $10,000 or you have
to chain yourself to a tree as loggers
are about to cut it down you probably
won't get a lot of members you say to
someone who wants to become an
evangelist for the environment take a
shorter shower recycle your cans and
bottles and newspapers you want to give
them a slippery slope suck them into
your cause just remember okay when all
things are said and done it is all about
spreading the good news good news that
you make people more creative more
productive that you're denting the
universe that you're changing the world
I like to call this guy's golden touch
so guys golden touch is not whenever I
touch turns to gold oh god I wish that
were true
I wish that were true guys golden touch
is whatever is gold guy touches so find
something great to find something great
reduce the friction learn to suck up get
it into that upper right-hand corner
build an ecosystem around it don't take
negativity and change the world and
that's the art of evangelism thank you
very much